(techno beats)
♪ Woah
♪ Girl
♪ Could you be the first
to take me all the way?
♪ I ain't a little boy no
more I'm throwing my toys away
♪ Trade my scooter
for a skateboard
♪ Leave the crust on my bread
♪ I'm done with taking baths,
I'm taking showers instead.
♪ Got my braces off
♪ I'm almost ready to shave
♪ I'm not afraid of cooties
♪ I'm a main man brave.
♪ So send in a selfie and
♪ In ten words or less
♪ Tell us why you
got to be the one
♪ To win this contest
♪ The first time is sacred
♪ Wanna share it with you
♪ To get with me naked
♪ Girl, one thing you got to do
♪ You've got to enter to yeah
♪ You've got one
chance to be with me
♪ You've got to enter to yeah
♪ To lose my virginity
♪ Must be 18 to win
♪ No purchase necessary
♪ I'm like oh, oh, yeah
♪ Yo, come on baby
♪ Enter to win
- [Voiceover] Kroll Show.
All new episodes
Tuesdays at 10:30
(techno beats)